bonjour à tous
j'espère que vous allez bien on se
retrouve aujourd'hui pour la vidéo faq
300 mille abonnés et on ne fait pas
seulement les trois cent mille abonnés
ont fait également l'anniversaire de la
chaîne puisqu'il se trouve que ça fait
exactement trois ans jour pour jour que
la chaîne le précepteur a été lancé et
plus accessoirement et de façon très
modeste il se trouve qu'on fait
également mon anniversaire puisque j'ai
aujourd'hui 35 ans et ne me dites pas
que je ne les fais pas parce que je sais
que c'est faux alors on commence à
répondre à vos questions quelques
petites annonces donc tout d'abord je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez désormais
écouter l'intégralité de mes épisodes en
format podcast que ce soit sur apple
podcast que ce soit sur deezer ou sur
spotify je sais que vous êtes
extrêmement nombreux à m'écouter en
podcast pour des raisons pratiques et
parce que mes épisodes s'écoute
davantage qu'ils ne se regardent ou pour
ceux qui n'étaient pas encore au courant
tous mes épisodes sont disponibles en
podcast
les liens sont dans la description la
deuxième annonce c'est que j'ai ouvert
une page patriotes à leur patronne
qu'est ce que c'est bien c'est un petit
peu l'équivalent de tipi pour ceux qui
connaissent c'est une plateforme sur
laquelle vous avez la possibilité de
rémunérer de faire un don à vos
créateurs préférés et il se trouve que
sur patriote vous aurez accès à un
certain nombre davantage d' avantages
matériels mais davantage également en
termes de publications inédites
donc si vous souhaitez me soutenir et
m'encourager à continuer mon travail via
n'hésitez pas à consulter ma page
patronne le lien est dans la description
troisième annonce je vous invite à me
rejoindre sur les réseaux sociaux et
notamment sur instagram parce que c'est
sur cette plateforme que je suis le plus
actif et d'ailleurs je sais que certains
vont tomber sur cette vidéo sans savoir
que j'organisais une faq
donc si vous voulez être tenu informé de
mai actualités et des prochaines faq que
je vais organiser le mieux de me suivre
directement sur les réseaux sociaux
et enfin je souhaitais remercier
chaleureusement toutes les personnes qui
me soutiennent que ce soit par les
abonnements premium sur youtube
que ce soit sur tipi ou sur paypal parce
que c'est grâce à vous que je peux
aujourd'hui me permettre de consacrer
100% montant à la réalisation de mes
vidéos
c'est grâce à vous que dès la rentrée
prochaine
et pouvoir mettre entre parenthèses mon
activité professionnelle pour me
consacrer à plein temps à youtube
donc sachez que je suis parfaitement
conscient que cette situation c'est à
vous que je la dois et que grâce à votre
soutien grandissant je vais pouvoir
continuer à vous proposer des épisodes
régulièrement des épisodes qui seront de
plus en plus de travailler de plus en
plus approfondie
il est évident que si vous n'étiez pas
aussi nombreux à me soutenir
il me serait tout simplement impossible
de dégager du temps pour réaliser ces
vidéos et d'en faire mon activité
principale
voilà ces annonces et en fait on va
maintenant pouvoir passer aux réponses à
vos questions
et comme d'habitude désolé à tous ceux
dont je n'ai pas retenu la question
évidemment vous aurez d'autres occasions
de me poser vos questions à l'avenir on
y va première question penser tu que tu
es format de vidéo en voix off sans
montage marcherait aussi bien alors je
répondrai à la fois oui et non oui parce
que sur mon ancienne chaîne youtube
j'avais déjà commencé à publier des
épisodes purement audio sans aucun
montage etc épisode avait très bien
fonctionné
donc je me doutais qu'en en important ce
format sur ma chaîne le précepteur ça
allait marcher
d'autant que beaucoup d'abonnés me
réclamer le retour de ce format par
contre ce qui est vrai et d'ailleurs
j'ai récemment eu l'occasion d'en parler
dans un entretien avec ce talent le loup
de la chaîne marketing magna je lui ai
expliqué que ce format aller totalement
à contre-courant des codes habituels des
vidéos youtube qui sont généralement
très rythmé très dynamique et
paradoxalement je suis convaincu qu
énormément de personnes ne sont pas
séduite par ce genre de format trop
dynamique que beaucoup de personnes
aiment des vidéos plutôt calme plutôt
lente ce que j'appelle des formats
méditatif c'est à dire des vidéos qui
laisse le temps et qui laisse la place à
la réflexion des formats dans lesquelles
le vidéaste ne prend pas l'esprit de
l'auditeur en otage mais au contraire va
laisser toute latitude à l'esprit de
l'auditeur pour pouvoir écouter de façon
active
on dirait que c'est vraiment la chose à
laquelle je tiens le plus dans mes
épisodes c'est que vous soyez actif dans
votre réflexion et que vous ne soyez pas
simplement dans la position d'auditeurs
ça ne m'intéresse pas que vous
moutier sans comprendre la moitié de ce
que je raconte ça ne m'intéresse pas que
vous vous disiez oh la la il emploie des
mots techniques il a du vocabulaire il a
des connaissances
donc ça veut dire que ce qu'il dit est
forcément intéressant personnellement ce
n'est pas du tout ma manière de
fonctionner c'est pas du tout la manière
dont je vois les choses
pour ma part la plus grande
gratification que je puisse obtenir à
travers mon travail sur youtube c'est de
me dire que des personnes qui à priori
ne se sentait pas en capacité de
s'intéresser à la philosophie puisse
finalement se dire en fait j'en suis
capable
j'en suis capable aussi bien que
n'importe qui d'autre j'en suis capable
même si je n'ai pas suivi de hautes
études philosophiques ou littéraire
parce que c'est ça en réalité ma mission
à travers mes épisodes et à travers le
travail que je fournis c'est de montrer
que n'importe quelle personne qui a un
esprit qui fonctionne est une personne
qui est capable de s'intéresser à la
philosophie qui est capable de
progresser en philosophie et si vous
faites partie de ces personnes qui
arrivent à m'écouter pendant 30 40 ou 50
minutes en vous disant à l'arrivée j'ai
tout compris
c'est la plus grande des satisfactions
que je puisse avoir question suivante
des conseils pour commencer à lire de la
philo je trouve les livres un peu
compliqué alors ça c'est une question à
laquelle j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
répondre
donc je vais réitérer ma réponse si vous
vous intéressez à la philosophie mais
que vous n'avez pas trouvé un livre de
vulgarisation ou un livre d'
introduction à la philosophie
je ne peux que vous conseiller d'aller
sur mon site internet www.la tirer
précepteur point fr et de cliquer sur
l'onglet télécharger mon livre dont je
vous ai mis le lien dans la description
et en commentaire épinglés et là vous
allez tomber sur mon livre tous
philosophes point d'interrogation dans
lequel j'essaye de vous initier à la
réflexion philosophique à partir de dix
phrases de la vie quotidienne dix
phrases de la vie tous les jours que
j'analyse sous un angle philosophique
pour vous montrer que sans même nous en
rendre compte
les phrases que nous prononçons au
quotidien sont chargés philosophiquement
elles contiennent ce que j'appelle un
inconscient philosophiques comme par
exemple la célèbre phrase qu'on entend
chez les enfants je n'ai pas fait exprès
et bien dans mon livre
j'analyse cette phrase parmi d'autres et
je montre que cette phrase témoigne
d'une adhésion à la philosophie morale
de kant parce que quand tu considères
que ce qui fait la moralité du
action c'est l'intention qui lie à
derrière cette action et cette
conception morale s'oppose à la
conception utilitariste par exemple de
jeremy bentham puisque chez bentham une
action et morale c'est à la des
conséquences positives en termes de
bien-être collectif
donc vous voyez qu'à travers cette
phrase tout à fait anodine je n'ai pas
fait exprès eh bien on peut déployer une
analyse philosophique on peut déployer
une interprétation philosophique et
c'est ça que je fais dans mon livre tous
philosophes que je vous invite
évidemment à télécharger question
suivante qui est un philosophe préféré
toutes époques confondues
je répondrai que c'est eagle mon
philosophe préféré vient ensuite spinoza
et enfin platon question suivante que
réponds-tu aux gens qui disent que la
philosophie n'est rien d'autre que de la
masturbation intellectuelle
je répondrai qui n'ont pas toujours tort
c'est vrai que beaucoup de personnes
considèrent la philosophie comme l'art
de faire le malin concrètement c'est à
dire l'art de montrer qu'on a une pensée
plus élevée que celle du commun des
mortels
l'art de la distinction intellectuelle
personnellement ce n'est pas la
conception que j'ai de la philosophie ce
n'est pas non plus la pratique que j'ai
la philosophie mais force est de
constater que dans les faits c'est
souvent à des fins d'ego à des fins de
posture et à des fins d'intimidation
intellectuelle que la philosophie est
utilisée question suivante comment
parviens tu à faire la part des choses à
bâtir ton regard sur la vie lorsque les
différentes philosophies que tu étudies
ont des concepts si différent parfois
contradictoires
en somme comment fais tu pour ne pas te
sentir perdus alors effectivement brian
tuer le doigt sur une réalité qui est
que dans mes épisodes
j'aborde des courants philosophiques qui
sont parfois aux antipodes les uns des
autres
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui fait que
certaines personnes ont du mal à me
situer elles ont du mal à me cerner
parce qu'elle se demande qu'est-ce que
moi j'en pense bien moi je n'en pense
rien parce que mon travail
ce n'est pas de vous dire ce que j'en
pense mon travail c'est de vous donner
les outils pour que vous puissiez savoir
ce que vous en pensez
voyez c'est là la différence c'est que
pour moi la philosophie ce n'est pas
vendre de la pensée c'était pas vous
dire ce qui est vrai ce qu'il faut ce
qui est bien ce qui est mal
parce que s'ils voulaient savoir ce qui
est bien ou ce qui est mal vous n'avez
qu'à demander à votre père vous n'avez
qu'à demander à votre prêtre vous n'avez
qu'à demander à votre femme
mais ce n'est pas à moi charles robin
que vous devez demander ce qui est bien
ce qui est mal ce qui est vrai et ce qui
est faux maintenant pour répondre plus
directement à ta question
il est vrai que pour ma part j'ai besoin
de pouvoir être au moins en partie
d'accord avec les auteurs dont je parle
sur ma chaîne être en partie d'accord
avec les auteurs que j'aborde sur ma
chaîne ça signifie que j'ai besoin
d'identifier chez eux un fip de
raisonnement que j'estime cohérent que
j'estime logique dans un certains
paradigmes de penser donc quand je parle
de nietzsche j'essaie de faire parler
nietzsche j'essaie de retranscrire de
reconstituer le fil de la pensée de
nietzsche qui l'amène à écrire ce qu'il
écrit et donc la question n'est plus de
savoir si je suis d'accord ou pas
d'accord
la question c'est de savoir est ce que
j'arrive à me transposer suffisamment
dans son esprit pour que la présentation
que je vous fais de son oeuvre soit
conforme soit fidèle à la réalité de son
message philosophique moi c'est la seule
question que je me pose quand j'aborde
un auteur c'est de savoir est-ce que je
suis fidèle à l'esprit de sa pensée
est-ce que je suis suffisamment honnête
intellectuellement pour ne pas faire
passer mes propres convictions ne pas
faire passer ma propre vision du monde
par dessus la vision de l'auteur dont je
parle parce que mon objectif n'est pas
de faire triompher une philosophie
plutôt qu'une autre
je n'ai aucun intérêt à faire triompher
une philosophie plutôt qu'une autre au
seul intérêt c'est que vous ressortiez
d'un des épisodes en vous disant j'ai
compris ce que voulait dire cet auteur
et comme j'ai pu dire tout à l'heure le
philosophe que je place en numéro un sur
le podium
segel or à ce jour combien d'épisodes
est-ce que j'ai consacré à eagle sur la
chaîne de 2 seulement et j'ai réalisé un
épisode sur sartre alors que je ne
partage pas du tout sa vision du monde
j'ai réalisé un épisode sur
l'utilitarisme de matam alors que je ne
partage pas du tout sa vision du monde
j'ai fait un épisode sur machiavel alors
que pour moi machiavel le principal
responsable philosophique de la
situation domination politique que nous
subissons actuellement
maintenant le fait est que je trouve
parmi tous les auteurs que j'aborde sur
ma chaîne au delà de leurs
contradictions
au delà de leurs antinomie
intellectuelle
je le retrouve de l'intelligence je le
retrouve de la finesse critique et pour
moi c'est ça le carburant de la
philosophie c'est la stimulation
intellectuelle
c'est l'intelligence et la finesse
d'esprit et c'est ce qui fait que je
refuserai toujours de censurer un auteur
ou de l'occulté sous prétexte que je ne
partage pas ses idées ou sa vision du
monde
maintenant oui le fait est que c'est
compliqué de faire cohabiter des auteurs
aussi éloignés que peuvent l'être
sartre et platon ou que peuvent l'être
quand et bantam
mais justement tout l'intérêt là
l'intérêt de la réflexion l'intérêt de
la pensée c'est de se heurter à des
choses avec lesquelles on n'est pas
d'accord
j'avais un prof de philosophie à la fac
qui s'appelait françois zourabichvili
paix à son âme
et ce professeur un jour nous a dit une
phrase que j'ai retenu nous a dit mme
une pensée choquant c'est un pléonasme
parce qu'une pensée ne peut être que
choquante une pensée est un choc parce
qu'une pensée nous ébranle une pensée
elle nous force à la remise en cause
elle nous force à envisager d'autres
points de vue que le nôtre et c'est
comme ça que la pensée se construit par
confrontation avec l'altérité par
confrontation avec ce qui n'est pas
elles mêmes par confrontation avec ceux
qui s'opposent à elle et c'est ce qui
fait que je considère que la philosophie
c'est l'exact opposé du militantisme
parce que le militantisme c'est
considérer qu'on détient la vérité est
que notre travail c'est de propager
cette vérité auprès des autres alors que
la philosophie c'est exactement le
contraire
ça consiste à considérer qu'on ne
détient pas forcément la vérité mais que
c'est au contact de l'autre qu'on va
pouvoir se rapprocher de cette vérité
donc à toutes les personnes qui
considèrent que la philosophie n'est
qu'un outil pour servir la propagande de
leurs idées politiques je leur réponds
grand bien vous en face mais ce n'est
pas sur ma chaîne que vous allez trouver
des munitions promener votre combat
question suivante
bonsoir professeur doit-on avoir eu
nécessairement l'expérience de la vie
pour être un philosophe alors j'aurais
tendance à répondre que oui pour être
philosophe il est nécessaire d'avoir une
expérience de la vie
mais j'ajouterai à cela que l'expérience
en elle-même ne suffit pas
elle ne suffit pas parce que une
expérience sans attention portée aux
conséquences de nos actions ne mène à
rien la pensée se construit à partir de
l'expérience dès lors qu'on est attentif
aux conséquences de nos actions et 6 et
avoir de l'expérience pour avoir de
l'expérience et avoir répété dix fois
vingt fois ou cent fois les mêmes
erreurs et à ce moment là notre
expérience ne nous aura rien apporté
d'un point de vue philosophique pour ma
part telles que je vois les choses
l'expérience c'est l'équivalent des
travaux pratiques pour la pensée travaux
pratiques parce que ça permet de
confronter notre pensée à la réalité et
donc d'en observer les conséquences
puisqu'il pensait désincarné n'a aucune
raison d'être et observer les
conséquences de notre pensée sur la
réalité et sur les autres c'est un
excellent fertilisant de la réflexion et
c'est ça aussi qui va permettre de
constater les limites de notre pensée à
un moment donné je suis hégélien je
considère avec eagle que la conscience
ne progressent que par l'expérience il
ne progresse que par le surpassement
permanent d'elle même et qu'est ce qui
permet à la conscience de se surpasser
elle même est bien c'est de prendre
conscience c'est d'être attentive aux
conséquences de nos actions aux
conséquences de nos interactions avec le
monde et avec les autres et au terme de
chacune de nos expériences marquantes on
devrait être capable de formuler
l'enseignement qu'on en a tiré moi je
pense que c'est ça qu'on devrait
apprendre à nos enfants
être capable de formuler l'enseignement
qu'ils ont tiré d'une expérience parce
que ça c'est rendre la pensée vivante
c'est rendre la pensée incarner et
vouloir séparer la pensée du concret
vouloir séparer la pensée de
l'expérience et de la pratique du réel
je pense que c'est un total contresens
sur la nature même de la pensée question
suivante à quand un livre du précepteur
alors comme je le disais tout à l'heure
j'ai déjà écrit plusieurs livres dont un
que vous trouverez sur mon site internet
le lien est dans la description quant à
savoir si je vais sortir un nouveau
livre
eh bien je ne vous cacherai pas que
il songe de plus en plus que ça va se
faire mais que je ne préfère pour
l'instant pas m'avancer en termes de
délais parce que ça s'organise ça se
prépare
j'ai l'expérience de l'écriture et donc
je sais à quel point entre ce qu'on
annonce est ce qui arrive
l'écart peut être important donc pour
l'instant je me contenterai de vous
répondre que oui il y aura d'ici un
certain temps un livre du précepteur
question suivante est ce que tu lis
beaucoup
si oui sur quelle fréquence alors est ce
que je dis beaucoup c'est relatif mais
en tout cas je lis régulièrement et
d'ailleurs vous aurez constaté que j'ai
espaces et les délais de publication de
mes vidéos justement pour pouvoir
m'accorder un peu plus de temps pour les
lectures parce que je considère que
lorsqu'on veut proposer du contenu qui
se renouvelle
on ne peut pas simplement se reposer sur
nos souvenirs de lecture passé il faut
les actualiser il faut les poursuivre
donc en ce moment je lis beaucoup parce
que la lecture les livres c'est la
nourriture de l'esprit
et moi je suis quelqu'un qui aime bien
manger donc j'aime bien aller au
restaurant et j'aime bien me plonger
dans les livres parce que j'y trouve à
la fois la nourriture de mon corps et de
mon esprit question suivante combien de
temps de préparation pour une vidéo de
40 minutes
alors pour une vidéo de 40 minutes j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de publier une story
instagram pour ceux que ça intéresse sur
le processus de création de mes épisodes
on va dire que pour un épisode de 40
minutes il faut compter environ 20
heures de travail préparatoire que ce
soit le travail de lecture que ce soit
le travail de préparation du plan que je
vais suivre dans chacun de mes épisodes
également le travail de montage
notamment du montage audio qui est le la
partie la plus longue de mon travail de
montage je ne vous cache pas que parfois
je peux passer entre cinq et dix heures
de montage pour un seul épisode plus le
temps de la mise en ligne si on met tout
ça bout à bout
on arrive très facilement à une
vingtaine d'heures voire une trentaine
d'heures par épisode
question suivante qu'est ce que ça te
fait d'être le prof de philo le plus
sexy de france
je dirais que cette affirmation n'étant
pas sourcées je me garderai bien de la
commenter
quel philosophe parle de l'importance
des émotions dans l'évolution de la
conscience
alors là encore la première réponse qui
me vient à l'esprit c'est eagle parce
que hegel s'est intéressé au processus
d'évolution de la conscience et nous
explique bien que la conscience elle
évolue au contact du monde et elle
évolue notamment dans son rapport
conflictuel avec autrui est d'ailleurs
égale à une expression que j'aime
beaucoup
lorsqu'il parle de la rencontre de la
conscience avec autrui il parle de la
conscience malheureuse
c'est à dire de la conscience qui tout à
coup prend conscience qu'elle n'est pas
seule au monde
la conscience malheureuse c'est la
conscience qui fait le constat de son
échec est le constat de nos échecs c'est
ça le moteur de notre amélioration et
l'évolution de la conscience
elle passe par les émotions elle passe
par la colère elle passe par la
tristesse leur gré la déception
tout ça c'est positif in fine et tout ça
c'est positif
à l'arrivée c'est positif parce que
c'est par l'expérience des choses
négatives que l'on prend conscience de
ce qui est positif c'est ça que nous
explique eagle évidemment d'une manière
beaucoup plus subtil est beaucoup plus
profonde que je ne suis en train de le
faire actuellement
mais s'il ya un auteur a conseillée sur
le rôle des émotions dans l'évolution de
la conscience
ce sera forcément eagle question
suivante pensez vous qu'il y ait des
gens qui ont un esprit philosophique des
gens qui ont plus de dispositions à
philosopher oui je pense que certaines
personnes sont davantage disposés à
philosopher et ce sont généralement les
personnes qui ont à la fois la capacité
de douter des choses la capacité de
remettre en cause ce qu'elle croit être
vrai et se sont en même temps des
personnes qui ont une capacité à
organiser leurs idées parce que moi je
connais les noms de personnes qui ont
cette fois
culte et à produire du raisonnement et à
produire des idées mais sans la mise en
forme qui va avec
donc je dirais que si il n'y a ni la
capacité de se remettre en cause la
capacité de douter des choses que l'on
croît être vrai ni la capacité
d'organiser ses idées et de leur donner
une forme ce qui selon moi sont les deux
jambes sur lesquels marche le philosophe
s'il manque une de ses jambes selon moi
c'est très difficile d'avancer dans la
philosophie question suivante et tu
plutôt déterministe ou existentialiste
alors je te répondrais que ce n'est pas
du tout comme ça que je me pose la
question parce qu'être déterministe ou
existentialiste ce n'est pas une
alternative
ce n'est pas un choix qui exclurait
notre option
en réalité tout dépend de la perspective
dans laquelle je vais me placer c'est à
dire que d'un point de vue analytique
quand j'essaye de prendre du recul par
rapport à une situation à ce moment là
je vais plutôt me placer en déterministe
au sens où je vais essayer de comprendre
l'enchaînement des causes et des effets
qui ont conduit de manière inéluctable à
cette situation
donc je suis déterministe quand
j'analyse une situation mais je serais
plutôt existentialiste dans mon
comportement c'est à dire dans mon
rapport concret au monde parce que
j'estime que le seul auteur de ma
prochaine action c'est moi et donc si
c'est moi l'auteur de ma prochaine
action ça veut dire que seul mois et le
pouvoir de déterminer ma prochaine
action et j'ai beau savoir que chaque
choix que je fais que chaque décision
que je prends est influencée et
déterminée est conditionné par mon passé
par mon environnement ou par les idées
dont j'ai hérité
le fait est que dans mon expérience
concrète au monde aux autres et à la vie
c'est moi qui décide c'est moi qui
décide de répondre à ta question plutôt
qu'à une autre c'est moi qui décide de
porter cette chemise plutôt qu'une autre
et ça c'est quelque chose sur quoi je
tiens vraiment à un système c'est qu'une
vision du monde déterministe ne vous
prive pas de votre libre choix une
vision déterministe
elle est là pour après coup vous dire
voilà pourquoi vous avez choisi ce que
vous avez choisi mais une vision
déterminer
je ne vous dis pas que vous n'avez pas
choisi parce que le déterminisme c'est
peut-être un outil d'analysé extrêmement
performant mais le fait est que lorsque
vous êtes confrontés à une décision à
prendre
le déterminisme vous vous en foutez vous
avez beau vous dire que le monde est
déterminé vous avez beau vous dire que
la prochaine action vous allez faire et
déterminé il n'empêche qu'à un moment
donné il va falloir que vous validiez
mentalement cette action donc à moins de
considérer que la conscience humaine
n'existe pas ou à moins de considérer
que nous ne sommes pas responsables de
la prochaine action que nous allons
faire le déterminisme ne vous servira à
rien le déterminisme est un outil
extrêmement performant pour ce qui est
de l'analyse en aucun cas le
déterminisme net un manuel qui va vous
dire comment vous devez agir question
suivante quelle est ta vidéo préférée
parmi celles que tu as réalisé alors
dans mon panthéon personnel de mes
vidéos youtube
je mettrai en premier ma vidéo sur booba
alors je sais que cette réponse va faire
des mécontents parce que certains
considèrent que booba est un personnage
beaucoup trop vulgaire beaucoup trop
grossier beaucoup trop inintéressant
pour qu'on puisse lui consacrer une
vidéo sur une chaîne de philosophie mais
le fait est que pour moi techniquement
esthétiquement et même sur le plan du
message notamment du message final je
considère que c'est l'une de mes plus
belles réalisations
alors évidemment sur le fond sur la
profondeur philosophique
ce n'est pas la vidéo sur mon bac je
mettrai en numéro un ce serait plutôt ma
vidéo sur prométhée parce que ma vidéo
sur prométhée je pense touche à des
questions extrêmement profonde de la
condition humaine et aussi parce que
j'aime beaucoup l'idée de mêler
philosophie et mythologies parce que je
fais partie de ceux qui considèrent que
la mythologie
c'est un recueil de sagesse c'est un
recueil de sagesse qui nous a été légué
par des individus qui manifestement ne
possédez pas notre niveau d'évolution
technique et notre niveau de
connaissance et qui pourtant ont produit
des oeuvres ont produit des textes
puis des mythes et qui éclaire notre
condition humaine beaucoup mieux que ne
le ferait n'importe quelle encyclopédie
donc ma vidéo sur prométhée jeu la
placerait parmi mes préférés sur ma
chaîne est évidemment ma première vidéo
sur le stoïcisme qui fait partie de mes
préférés et qui si on s'en tient aux
score fait également partie de vos
préférées question suivante si tu devais
l'enseigné qu'un seul principe de
philosophie lequel choisirais tu si je
ne devais enseigner qu'un seul principe
serait celui de dialectique le principe
de la dialectique c'est de dire que
chaque chose qui évolue passe
nécessairement par la rencontre avec son
contraire est passé par la rencontre
avec son contraire ça veut dire que ce
que l'on croit parfois être un échec est
en réalité le début de notre progression
c'est dire qu'on ne progresse réellement
que dans l'adversité qu'on progresse
réellement que dans la rencontre
conflictuelles avec ce qui n'est pas
nous et qu'au lieu de rejeter ce qui
n'est pas nous comme quelque chose que
l'on ne veut pas côtoyé au contraire se
dire que c'est par cette confrontation
qu'on va véritablement progresser et
devenir ce que nous sommes voilà pour
cette réponse question suivante comment
tu géré la pression de youtube si
pression il y a alors s'agissant de mon
cas personnel
la pression liée à youtube je ne la sens
absolument pas ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que avoir 300 mille abonnés
aujourd'hui pour moi ce n'est que du
positif
ce n'est que de la gratification ce
n'est que de la récompense à aucun
moment ces trois cent mille abonnés ne
constitue pour moi une source de
pression qui fait que je devrai tout à
coup me demander si ce que je dis et
pertinents faire attention à ne pas
vexer ou un pas froisser certaines
sensibilités
ça ne conduit pas non plus à me dire que
je devrais me censurer sur certains
sujets
j'aurais presque tendance à dire que
c'est même le contraire parce que plus
j'avance dans ma carrière sur youtube et
plus je suis à l'aise et que ce qui par
le passé pouvait être source de pression
contrainte aujourd'hui ne l'est plus du
tout alors il trouve que je ne me
considère pas du tout comme youtube
heures au sens où je ne participe pas du
tout aux folklores youtube est ce qu au
sens où je ne me rends pas dans les
conventions et je n'ai pas beaucoup de
connaissances dans ce milieu donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui m'aide avoir du
détachement par rapport à youtube et
puis surtout ma vie ne dépend pas de
youtube
ma vie ne dépend pas du nombre de vues
que je vais réaliser sur ma prochaine
vidéo
non pas que ça n'a pas d'importance mais
youtube représente pour moi une aventure
et une opportunité une opportunité que
j'ai saisie mais si demain tout ça
devait disparaître bien je sais que ma
vie continuerait sous d'autres cieux
et comme j'ai une expérience du travail
assez riche comme j'ai déjà exercé
plusieurs emplois totalement différents
les uns des autres
ben je sais très bien que si demain
youtube n'existe plus je me reconvertir
est facilement donc pas de pression pour
ma part par rapport à youtube
si ce n'est la pression que je m'inflige
à moi même de produire un contenu que
j'espère de qualité à chaque fois un peu
meilleures questions suivantes quels
conseils pourrais-tu donner à nous
autres qui à me rioux on faire des
vidéos sur la pédagogie et la didactique
alors le seul et unique conseil que je
donnerais à n'importe quelle personne
qui a ne serait ce que l'idée je parle
même pas du projet ou de l'ambition mais
l'idée de créer sa chaîne pour
transmettre des connaissances pour
transmettre sa passion
le seul conseil que je peux donner ses
fons fonce et ne pose aucune question
qui serait de nature à ralentir la
concrétisation de ce projet parce qu'en
réalité la grande majorité des projets
qui ne se réalisent pas ne se réalisent
pas par peur de passer à l'action
donc il n'ya pas de manuels il n'y a pas
de mode d'emploi sur mesure qui dit à
chaque personne comment créer sa chaîne
youtube tout ce qu'il y assez de
l'expérience c'est du travail c'est de
l'apprentissage et de l'amélioration qui
se fait progressivement qui se fait dans
le temps et qui se fait en étant
attentif aux petits détails qui font la
différence
moi par exemple si je regarde les
premières vidéos qui se
publiée sur ma chaîne je me sens très
mal je me sens très mal parce que je
trouve que ces vidéos sont très
mauvaises elles sont très mauvaises sur
la forme
elles sont très mauvaises techniquement
elles sont très mauvaises à de très
nombreux égards mais le fait est que
c'est parce que je suis passé par là
qu'aujourd'hui je peux proposer des
vidéos dont je sois un tant soit peu
satisfait donc ne vous posez pas de
questions inutiles chapelle questions
inutiles
une question qui va vous entravé dans le
processus de réalisation de vous même
faites ce que vous avez à faire de toute
façon vous ne jouez pas votre vie de
toute façon les seules personnes qui
vont vous faire des critiques ou des
remarques négatives sont des personnes
qui n'auront pas eu le courage que vous
vous avez eu de vous lancer donc ces
critiques ne sont pas ces critiques
n'ont aucune consistance et il
n'appartient qu'à vous de réaliser ce
qui se trouve dans votre esprit
question suivante pourquoi est-ce qu'on
a tendance à procrastiner parce que
l'être humain aime la facilité il est
toujours plus facile de descendre les
escaliers que de les monter et que quand
ce qu'on a affaire n'a pas une urgence
vitale
on a tendance à repousser moment de
déployer un effort question suivante que
penses tu de l'hermétisme l'hermétisme
est une tradition et une philosophie que
je connais assez bien et dont je
parlerai un jour en vidéo ne penses tu
pas que l'espérance peut dans certains
cas être bénéfique car elle peut induire
un effet placebo notable je demande ça
parce que le stoïcisme la rejette
alors je dirais qu'il faut faire
attention à distinguer deux choses
c'est l'espoir et l'espérance
l'espérance c'est un sentiment diffus et
prolongée de confiance et de sérénité
par rapport à l'avenir
par contre l'espoir l'espoir qu'est ce
que c'est c'est une attente
d'amélioration c'est vouloir que demain
soit meilleur qu'aujourd'hui et il n'y a
rien de mal dans le fait de désirer que
demain soit meilleur qu'aujourd'hui mais
simplement ce désir a de grandes chances
d'être déçus et à ce moment là l'espoir
va se convertir en désespoir et c'est
pour cette raison précise
que les stoïciens rejette et d'une
certaine manière prohibe l'espoir parce
que l'espoir n'est basée que sur les
choses qui ne dépendent pas de nous
c'est pour ça que dans ma dernière vidéo
sur le stoïcisme
j'ai bien fait la différence entre
l'espoir et le pouvoir parce que
l'espoir est lié à ce qui ne dépend pas
de nous alors que le pouvoir est liée à
ce qui dépend de nous et donc le fait
d'espérer qu'il fera beau demain c'est
quelque chose qui vous condamne à la
déception si demain il ne fait pas beau
alors que prévoir plusieurs options
selon le temps qu'il fera demain c'est
vous garantir que quel que soit le temps
qu'il va faire demain
vous ne serez pas déçus donc au lieu
d'espérer quelque chose sur quoi vous
allez faire tapis sur quoi vous allez
tout misé demandez vous plutôt qu'est ce
que vous feriez dans chaque situation
qui peut éventuellement se présenter
et dans ce cas là vous remplacez
l'espoir par le pouvoir vont remplacer
latentes liées à ce qui ne dépend pas de
vous par le résultat lié à ce qui dépend
de vous question suivante si la
philosophie n'était pas ton premier
amour quel autre métier aurais-tu choisi
c'est une jolie question si la
philosophie n'avait pas été mon premier
amour
j'aurais peut-être choisi l'architecturé
alors je sais que ça paraît étrange
parce que je n'ai jamais parlé de mon
goût pour l'architecturé sur cette
chaîne mais il faut savoir que
l'architecturé la philosophie ont en
commun le fait d'assembler des éléments
qui vont donner un ensemble cohérent et
solide et qui vont d'ailleurs donné
naissance à quelque chose dans quoi on
va pouvoir habiter et d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas pour rien qu'on emploie
l'expression de monuments de la
philosophie pour parler de certains
auteurs ou de certaines oeuvres et ce
qui fait la grandeur d'un monument c'est
à la fois sa beauté et sa solidité
donc si je n'avais pas choisi la
philosophie c'est à dire larchitecture
de la pensée j'aurais choisi
larchitecture delapierre question
suivante que faire face aux doutes
notamment le doute sur ses propres
capacités
alors je te répondrais que le doute tu
le convoque dans son bureau
tu la trappe par le col et tu lui dis
quand j'aurai besoin de réfléchir quand
j'aurai besoin de remettre les choses en
cause je te précise
par contre quand je suis en train d'agir
tu te tais il ne faut surtout pas
confondre le doute dans la réflexion et
le doute dans l'action le doubs dans la
réflexion est absolument indispensable
c'est ce qui va nous permettre de
remettre en cause ce que l'on croyait
être vrai c'est ce qui va nous permettre
de devenir sensible à un autre point de
vue que le nôtre et tout ça c'est
bénéfique pour la pensée alors que le
doute dans l'action c'est au contraire
ce qui va nous ralentir c'est ce qui va
nous entraver et nous paralyser et si je
suis le premier à promouvoir le doute
dans la réflexion je suis également le
premier à proscrire le doute dans
l'action donc le doute est une très
bonne chose lorsqu'il s'agit d'améliorer
sa compréhension du monde mais c'est le
pire des alliés lorsqu'il s'agit de
passer à l'action
question suivante quel est le trait de
personnalité que tu as depuis enfants
dont tu es le plus fier alors je sais
pas si je pourrai dire que j'en suis
fier mais en tout cas je n'en ai pas
honte
c'est mon entêtement ma persistance ma
persévérance
donc selon le mot qu'on va employer ce
sera qualifié comme un défaut comme une
qualité mais en tout cas c'est un trait
de personnalité que j'ai depuis que je
suis tout petit je me souviens que
j'étais enfant j'étais surpris de la
malléabilité de certaines personnes de
leur caractère influençable et du fait
que ces personnes parfois se laisser
convaincre
j'insiste bien sur la tournure passive
se laisser convaincre par des choses
dont je voyais dans leurs yeux qu'elle
n'y croyait pas vraiment et je me disais
mais qu'est ce qui fait un moment donné
que l'on peut suivre un raisonnement ou
une personne en laquelle on ne croit pas
mon obstination ma persévérance quel que
soit le nom qu'on lui donne
c'est ce qui m'a permis de réaliser tous
les projets de ma vie c'est ce qui m'a
permis de maintenir le cap de maintenir
mes efforts
quand beaucoup de personnes me faisait
savoir que c'était inutile que je
m'obstine est dans une voie de garage ou
dans quelque chose qui ne pourrait que
me rendre malheureux je n'en veux pas à
ces personnes parce que dans leur esprit
c'était un conseil qui était motivée par
de la bienveillance et je conçois que ça
peut être quelque chose
d'assez surprenant peut-être même d'
assez agaçant au quotidien de vivre avec
quelqu'un qui est obstiné qui ne veut
jamais en démordre le fait est que mon
obstination prend rarement la forme de
la mauvaise foi et qu'il s'agit plutôt
d'une obstination dans l'action
question suivante qu'est ce père tu de
la part du peuple alors je n'espère
absolument rien de la part du peuple
tout simplement parce que je ne suis pas
en position d'espérer quoi que ce soit
de la part de qui que ce soit je sais
que quand j'explique ça souvent beaucoup
de personnes ne comprennent pas ce que
je veux dire ne comprennent pas qu'on
puisse ne rien attendre ou ne rien
espérer de la part des autres sans que
ça ne soit une manière de se retirer du
monde mais je tiens à dire que c'est
exactement contraire c'est quand vous
n'attendez plus rien d autre que vous
êtes prêts à les accepter que vous êtes
prêts à les accepter comme ils sont avec
leurs défauts et leurs qualités
à partir du moment où vous cessez de
placer des attentes dans l'autre vous
devenez libre parce que vous n'êtes plus
assujettis à des choses qui sont
fondamentalement hors de votre contrôle
donc j'essaye d'appliquer la règle de
l'amour du prochain
sans rien attendre de lui sans rien
exiger de lui
et si un jour l'autre me déçoit et bien
ce moment là je me détournerai de
l'autre pour poursuivre mon chemin
chacun fait ce qu'il a à faire et moi je
n'ai pas à dire ce que les autres ont à
faire je suis un être humain comme
n'importe quel autre être humain est la
seule personne vis-à-vis de qui je
pourrais avoir des attentes c'est moi
même question suivante que dirais-tu sur
le narcissisme physique qu'on voit sur
les réseaux sociaux
alors ça c'est une question sur laquelle
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de donner mon
point de vue dans un épisode
un épisode dans lequel je
je m'étonnais qu'on soit si critique
envers le narcissisme physique sur les
réseaux sociaux
le narcissisme physique c'est à dire le
fait de se prendre en photo
le fait de prendre son corps en photo je
trouvais très étonnant de s'offusquer de
cette forme de narcissisme sans jamais
s'offusquer d'une autre forme de
narcissisme que je trouve beaucoup plus
polluante qui est le narcissisme des
opinions
le narcissisme des opinions c'est ce
besoin compulsif de donner notre avis
sur une publication qui généralement ne
nous concerne que de très loin mais sur
laquelle on a un avis sur laquelle on a
une position que l'on cherche à faire
savoir
et si d'aventuré certaines personnes et
mettait un désaccord avec nous et bien
on va absolument vouloir les persuader
que nous avons raison et que l'autre à
tort ce narcissisme des opinions qui
fait qu'on ne se rend même pas compte
qu'on étale qu'on expose qu'on exhibe
ses opinions avec beaucoup moins de
pudeur et de décence que certaines
personnes exhibent leur corps sur les
réseaux sociaux
il y à une vulgarité parfois dans l'état
l'âge de nos opinions dont on ne se rend
même pas compte tellement nous y sommes
habitués
parce que nourri au lait du débat
médiatique
nous avons tendance à penser que toute
modalité du rapport à autrui est
construite sur le conflit est construite
sur la confrontation et le débat et le
principe du débat c'est quoi c'est de
convaincre l'autre que nous avons raison
et à défaut de convaincre l'autre au
moins de convaincre l'assistance de
convaincre le public et c'est un petit
peu ça qui se joue parfois dans les fils
de commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
où chacun va vouloir absolument montrer
que c'est lui qui a raison
et cet étalage des opinions je n'hésite
pas à le considérer comme étant
finalement beaucoup plus vulgaire et
beaucoup plus nuisible que le
narcissisme physique que l'on peut
observer sur les réseaux sociaux
question suivante le fait de coller des
étiquettes aux gens pour ne plus avoir à
dialoguer tu en penses quoi
alors j'en pense que c'est une technique
bien pratique qui encore
bel avenir devant elle parce que ça
permet de disqualifier de discréditer un
propos non pas sur le fond non pas sur
le contenu argumentatif mais sur
l'appartenance supposée de celui qui
incarne ce discours a un groupe un
groupe supposé méprisable ou supposés
non crédible cette technique elle porte
un nom ça s'appelle le déshonneur par
association et c'est une technique qui
selon moi trahi davantage l'absence
d'argumentation et l'absence de réponses
rationnelles à un argument parce que
c'est devenu très à la mode de pensée
qu'il suffirait de démontrer
l'appartenance ou la proximité d'un
individu avec tel ou tel groupe que ce
serait suffisant pour disqualifier son
propos sauf que ça marche pas comme ça
ça marche pas comme ça parce qu'il
existe quelque chose qui s'appelle les
idées et dans notre pays dans notre
civilisation et à notre époque
eh bien on considère que lorsqu'on n'est
pas d'accord avec les idées de quelqu'un
et bien c'est aux idées qu'on va s'en
prendre ce qui me semblent être frappés
du sceau du bon sens mais manifestement
certaines personnes continuent de croire
que c'est une technique qui fonctionne
et que c'est une technique qui a une
valeur sur le plan intellectuel question
suivante comment peut-on expliquer
l'hypocrisie au sein de notre société
alors je te répondrai en deux temps un
premier temps l'hypocrisie est une
condition de la coexistence au sein de
la société
l'hypocrisie c'est la tendance à ne pas
dire en face ce que l'on pense vraiment
mais si on observe bien les relations
sociales telles qu'elles ont lieu autour
de nous et on s'aperçoit que
l'hypocrisie est une sorte de norme est
une sorte de règle générale et c'est
tout à fait normal que ce soit une norme
parce que le principe même de la vie en
société donc de la coexistence pacifique
entre des individus
son principe même c'est la prohibition
de la pulsion c'est la répression de nos
instincts agressifs et donc l'hypocrisie
c'est une manière détournée c'est une
manière indirecte d'exprimer notre
agressivité d'exprimer notre penchant au
conflit de manière inoffensive pour
l'équilibré et la stabilité de la
société
maintenant 2e temps de ma réponse
l'hypocrisie c'est ce vis-à-vis de quoi
on doit lutter en nous mêmes parce que
très souvent on reproche à l'autre son
hypocrisie
mais on se montre très indulgent envers
notre propre hypocrisie hypocrisie
étymologiquement c'est ce que l'on cache
c'est ce que l'on dissimule et donc je
dirais que la meilleure manière de ne
pas soi même sombré dans l'hypocrisie
c'est tout simplement de s'abstenir
d'émettre un jugement négatif à
l'endroit de quelqu'un
lorsque l'on n'est pas prêt à l'assumer
en face question suivante quel lien
peut-on faire entre la philosophie et
les avancées en neurosciences alors le
lien qu'on peut faire concrètement entre
philosophie et neurosciences
j'envoie un en particulier c'est sur le
sujet de la conscience parce qu'il est
certain que si les avancées en
neurosciences nous permettent de mieux
appréhender cet objet proprement humain
qui est la conscience
il est certain que le questionnement
philosophique va s'en trouver chamboulés
si on est capable de savoir comment
fonctionne la conscience quels sont les
mécanismes qui la régissent qu'est ce
qui permet l'évolution la conscience
quels rapports la conscience entretien
avec le cerveau est ce que c'est un
rapport de dépendance ou un rapport
d'autonomie toutes ces questions qui
n'ont pas été résolues par la
philosophie peuvent aujourd'hui être
abordée de manière scientifique par les
neurosciences et dans tous les cas
j'aimerais vivre assez longtemps pour
voir les nouvelles données que ces
avancées vont nous permettre d'obtenir
et pour participer à la réflexion
philosophique général qui va naître de
ces découvertes question suivante qu'est
ce que le sport tu apportes dans la vie
le sport m'apporte une discipline le
sport m'apporte un bien-être et il
m'apporte une sensation de présence à
moi même que je ne pourrais pas éprouver
autrement je n'ai jamais caché le fait
que j'aimais le sport et que je
le dissocier pas l'activité
philosophique de l'activité sportive
pour moi ce sont les deux faces de la
même pièce et je continuerai à militer
jusqu'au bout pour défendre les valeurs
du sport et pour défendre les vertus du
sport parce qu'un esprit qui ne s'exerce
pas à penser le corps est un esprit qui
passe à côté de la moitié de la vie où
te vois-tu dans 10 ans alors
dans dix ans je me vois dans une grande
maison du sud de la france avec une
pièce en sous sol que j'aurais aménagé
de telle sorte qu'elles soient à la fois
un bar à vin et une bibliothèque
et dans cette pièce seront disposés sur
le sol des coussins sur lesquels on
pourra s'asseoir pour lire et seront
également installé des tables hautes
construite à partir de tonneaux de vin
récupérer mais au delà de la maison
j'habiterai dans dix ans il est fort
probable que je n'aurait toujours pas
divorcer de la philosophie et je serai
peut-être même encore en train de vous
en parler
dernière question quel est l'homme qui a
eu le plus d'influencé sur le cours de
votre vie et pourquoi alors ça c'est une
question difficile parce que l'homme qui
a eu le plus d'influencé dans ma vie
n'est certainement pas un philosophe
c'est certainement pas un un auteur que
j'ai pu lire dont j'aurais pu vous
parler l'homme qui a eu le plus
d'influencé dans ma vie c'est forcément
mon père parce que c'est le modèle
identitaire sur lequel tout enfant se
construit et ce qui est drôle c'est que
mon père c'est à la fois la personne à
qui je ressemble plus mais c'est aussi
la personne qui m'est le plus éloigné
mon père n'est pas un intellectuel mon
père n'est pas quelqu'un qui aime lire
ou qui a une passion pour la philosophie
par contre mon père est quelqu'un qui a
le cerveau qui fonctionne et qui a non
seulement l'esprit critique mais aussi
ce que j'appellerais
une finesse d'analysé une perspicacité
intellectuelle dont je crois une élue
même pas conscients et c'est là
justement où se trouve la principale
différence entre mon père et moi c'est
que je pense que mon père n'a pas
conscience de ses capacités
si bien qu'ils ne les a jamais vraiment
exploiter là où j'ai toujours mis un
point d'honneur à exploiter les
capacités dont j'avais hérité
parce que quand on hérite de
possibilités et nous sommes tous
héritiers de possibilités on a un devoir
qui est d'exploiter ses possibilités
quand vous avez conscience que vous
savez faire quelque chose pourquoi
priver le monde de cette chose pourquoi
avoir peur de ce que vous êtes capable
de faire
je fais aujourd'hui mais 35 ans lorsque
mon père avait 35 ans il avait déjà
trois enfants depuis longtemps et il se
lever tous les matins à 6 heures pour
aller travailler jusqu'à 22 heures
la personne qui a eu le plus d'influencé
sur moi est une personne qui m'a appris
le sens du mot courage et elle me l'a
d'autant mieux appris qu'elle ne me l'a
pas appris avec des mots mais qu'elles
me l'a appris par son comportement
aujourd'hui je peux dire que j'ai hérité
du courage de mon père parce qu'il a
réussi à mlle transmettre parce que pour
lui le courage allait de soi courage
c'est ce qu'on met en oeuvre quand
quelque chose
11 en vaut la peine et si pour vous il y
a quelque chose qui valent la peine
montrez le lui montrer le lui par votre
courage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]